okay so
ladies and gentlemen welcome to a
discussion session about
recovery for biddeford and the future of
our town center
and thank you all so much for joining us
on this
it's tuesday evening there we go
momentary pause um thank you to everyone
for meeting yourselves and there are
sort of
over 20 people on the call at the moment
um this is not me being
regimented need to make sure that we've
not got too much uh
sound interference i'm going to be
monitoring
the participants throughout
if you want to talk please just raise a
hand and we'll try and get to you as
soon as we can
um there is the chat function that's
activated
please make sure that throughout the
discussions that you're using that chat
um but as always please keep it polite
keep it positive and keep it respectful
and we will have
certain differences of opinion but
that's great hopefully that will be
constructive and move us forward to
a brighter place and i'm delighted
to welcome this evening ben stevenson
who has worked with a number of us
before in his role as
within the institute of place management
um ben
is with us today on as an independent uh
consultant
but brings with him a wealth of
knowledge experience and connections
that it's great to have
on board ben over to you thank you so
much
it's very very kind of you um and also
i bring with me a great love of
biddeford um it's quite a newfound love
i've i've only visited the town twice
and i was here last year with the ipm
back this year um i visited on a
particularly sunny day and
it was almost impossible to see anything
wrong with it um
maybe there isn't anything wrong with it
let's see if we can find find out
tonight
um chris you said before if people could
raise their hand i would suggest
probably if you want to raise your hand
to talk maybe use the function of
raising your hands it's much easier to
spot than if you're
or you're waving your hand around
because you've got sort of lots of
people here tonight
and so thanks so much for having me
and for also sharing your beautiful town
with me um
i'm i'm i have got a bit of experience
in
places and i'm a a fellow of the
institute of pace management
um and i've been working in places all
across the uk
for many years about 20 years now with a
background in
um business improvement districts um
and also around a street market
for a time um which is sort of
transformative thing
it changed to local economy for the
better
um i'm really involved in neighbourhood
planning i get involved with new
developers with local authorities all
sorts and
the the sort of basic function um that i
provide is to
try to understand a little bit about
local economies and
and advise on how local economies could
improve so
um as you might imagine i've been pretty
busy recently on the sort of covid
uh recovery stuff um and
um having been appointed to the high
streets task force
um as an expert i'm sort of working with
all sorts of different places so
and that's a bit of background um from
me
just if we i mean i'm hoping this isn't
going to be massively provocative
tonight
and uh i'm going to bring you some of
the learnings
uh that i've i've sort of brought with
me but the agenda
um is basically chris is going to start
off with a bit of an overview
about what's going on at the moment in
biddeford
um and what the future holds a little
bit for a bit of food some of which you
you will be i'm sure uh aware of but but
uh some some of you may may not be
and then i'm gonna have a we're going to
have a quick recap of
some of the vital and viable work that
we did last year not too focused on that
really looking forward from that and
then we're going to look at a bit about
what's changed with coronavirus and
throughout all of this we'd like you
to put your hand up and participate if
you can
um i've got some um examples for how
different places are managing recovery
really focusing on smaller towns
um uh just to sort of give you some
ideas about
how recovery might work in biddeford
um then uh we uh we're looking going to
look at the sort of barriers to success
um the action planning process itself so
really this is a very it's a
quick and dirty action plan it's not
going to be a
sort of a report that gathers dust on a
shelf for years and years and years
you've all seen many of those i'm sure
and and then we'll sort of go into the
next steps
so this was the day that i arrived this
photo you can see how
gloriously sunny it is so uh chris i'm
going to hand over to you
brilliant thank you i think
it's really exciting to be having this
discussion um about the future of
biddeford
because there's a lot going on and
there's a lot of positives
we know that there are challenges we
know there are all sorts of things that
still need working on
collectively but for those of you who
have not been aware we've recently
submitted
our future high street funds submission
for biddeford
so if you haven't already signed up for
information i would
really really really ask anyone who's
interested in regeneration
which you guys are because you're on
this call to go to
bid for biddeford.co.uk and i'll put
that in the chat in a minute
um and just sign up for to be kept
informed
because that could be an incredibly
transformative project for the heart of
biddeford
and in fact for the entire town and
surroundings
we then know that that couples with
brunswick wharf
and the opportunities that that presents
as well the two projects working in
tandem
and also before people start saying well
it's making the most of other assets
that we've got in the town
so how for example do we bring bridge
buildings back to life
there's a lot of work going on that and
equally how do we make the most of the
panhandle market
which i know that within the town
council
there's again a lot of hard work
investigating
how it can become more active and how it
can be
better utilized for our community and
for our local economy
right then going to move on pretty
please
um now we're sort of entering this
discussion
um having done a lot of engagement
a lot of learning a lot of um planning
as part of that future high street fund
uh process building up to the submission
in july
now one of the things that we did
working with a body called the onion
collective
did a large amount of community
engagement which led to a series of
findings which can be
seen at bit.ly forward slash knowing
biddeford
but that also then led into the creation
of a
theory of change that was approved by
biddeford town council
and which really should act as a kind of
a steer for all of our efforts
and i'm not just talking about torres
district council or biddeford town
council
but working collectively as a holistic
community
with business with charities
to really bring the town to life
interestingly there's all sorts of
points that are already starting to come
true on that it's interesting to see i'm
sure
counselor christie will smile when i
point out uh
2b point 3 parking uh improved parking
to be well signed and free for one hour
once two hours days well
we'll see how those trials go in the
near future um
so it'd be great if people sort of uh if
you haven't read this again that's
available on that bit dot l y and
forward slash knowing biddeford
and it just means that people can all be
working towards the same
end goals and really helping to create a
collective
difference um now uh before we
sort of move on with ben's bit and we're
gonna be aiming to finish
uh by eight o'clock at the absolute
latest um
so as i said thank you so much for being
with us on a tuesday night
and ben over to have some fun
uh thank you very much that's a bit fun
um
so let's look at some of the vitality
and viability work we did last year so
um just to sort of recap on it um i was
brought in
with um a colleague professor steve
millington
who is at an absolute authority on place
and done lots of work
uh with with places all up and down the
country
um and we were bought into to look at
these two concepts vitality and
viability and it's sort of in in very
brief terms vitality is essentially the
life of the
place and viability is its ability to be
able to
attract investment in the long term so
it's a sort of sustainability
and thing and and what we did as part of
that exercise i don't want to
run through it again and many of you
would have been there i know some of you
were
and was do a swot analysis on the place
and i'm particularly interested in
looking at the opportunities
and and i'm interested in asking you
whether or not you feel
that these opportunities are still the
key opportunities for benefit
particularly
in the post-covered landscape so just
running through them here
um one of the opportunities is space for
growth i think you know
um chris very uh ably just took you
through some of those there
um you know isaac's yard at brunswick
there's all sorts of
opportunity in all of those um
interesting i think the river is another
uh
base uh that can grow in terms of the
way that it's used
um enterprising people not something
that comes up a lot but a really
interesting one
in biddeford because it is such an
enterprising place
and there was the idea that maybe there
could be a bit
a slightly better connection with a
better connection between the sort of
supply and demand
side of things as far as trading hours
are concerned so you know
our shops always open when people need
them to be open or are they
open at the times when the shopkeepers
want them to be open for instance
um interesting questions around identity
which i want to delve into a little bit
further actually
um short-term parking obviously
let's hope that that's been resolved in
some way it'd be interesting again see
how that pans out
um is the other times white at the time
of day right
um you know is two hours the right the
right
uh a period of time and it are the car
parks the right ones
um transient employment is another good
one particularly given
uh the issues around youth uh employment
and and the opportunities that
that are around for them we've spoken
already about the river but the key side
as well
sounds like there's some interesting
problems um given that it's a
working key side about what you can
actually do with that so maybe there are
sort of more structural
um solutions to that problem uh and then
finally make more of that independent
retail offer and one of the
you know this is so key and particularly
for business that
um in many ways and i did find this uh
as i was talking to people in the town
there's a sort of sense that uh
biddeford has slightly ducked some of
the worst of the
post 2008 recession the out-of-town
shopping issues the internet shopping
um and indeed the sort of coronavirus
issues
because it's much more independent than
this
chains and that's when we look at what's
been going on in biddeford
um there is some vacancy and it really
felt to me as though the high street
um could have compared with other places
that i've seen not so bad but
you know particularly great architecture
actually on the street
but you've got some quite large losses
on the high street which i know
that torridge and others are working in
the town to
try to backfill but
some fantastic independent shops two of
which are here
one of the uh one of the sort of very
clear messages i got from one of the
independents in the town was having seen
independence like this
start up there's a real confidence to
start your own place
and it's that sort of it's that sense of
confidence to invest in your town that's
that i think is going to really stand
you in good so
really really good message there and
really interesting to talk to people
that run those businesses
uh and then just before we go on to
just before we turn over to you um the
other issue there
is honey market which was questioned
before now
one of the sort of prevailing um
issues that i think was was raised
before this idea that
that nobody walks up the hill to the
market so i've included here
um this poster for froome and in many
ways
biddeford and through them sort of
remind me of each other in their sort of
independent spirit
and they're sort of very you know sort
of forward thinking spirit and stuff
this is just to remind you that if the
offer is right people walk up the hill
and i know
that the town uh that the house is
working on this
moment but lots of ideas around event
you know that the market is an event
space
really sort of supported by the craft uh
um
units on the side there um and and and
that sort of thing
so lots to think about now what i wanted
to do is turn it over to you i've seen
there's quite a lot of
um chat in the chat
um does anybody uh adrian or chris want
to start talking talking us through
what's in that and indeed does anybody
want to raise their hand and
and talk about some of the issues that
we've raised here
yeah just then just going through the um
can you hear me okay
um look just looking through the chat
now um teresa makes a good point
um in terms of opportunities um also
um the bit of investigating obviously
with uh
things on the cycle routes and the cycle
paths i think in kenworth valley
um with westwood ho northern ecuador and
lincoln the taco trail a bit more
there is some work going on in the
background around that
it could be a long process but work is
again
ongoing with that um being actively
pushed as
as councilor christie says on there um
in terms of the hill
as well um joel mentions that
bellanos is always full and it's just up
next door i don't
uh not being a bit of a boy i'm not sure
what what that is but it's
obviously if that's something that's you
make that point of
you know if people got a reason to go up
that hill they will go and that looks
like somewhere that's um
that's obviously raising that point
quite well
um agreed apparently a market needs to
be turned
back to uh to a food hub potentially um
that's uh joanne joanne's point there we
at north devon food
co-op uh working the plan regenerate the
food economy in north devon so yeah some
good those are the points basically in
the chat
um up till there ben that is great thank
you does anybody want to uh
talk in person about what's going on and
got their hand up
it's unusually quiet from this bunch of
people in in the call
yeah i'm not used to most of these
people being quiet for this long at all
they must be
one of the other changes that we've seen
happening and i don't know whether this
sort of makes a difference in terms of
the local economy
but the sort of big news in appledore
about the the shipyards
um do we see that as having i know it's
not and it's not absolutely next door
but do we see that as having an effect
in terms of the money that's flowing
into
uh biddeford and then of course the
other one
is around the issue of the daytime
population so
uh more people working from home um what
does that mean in terms of the sort of
daytime spend that's available
will you see people in town a little bit
more
um are plans being made in terms of
things like um retail uh opening hours
or the evening economy this will just
speak to those structural changes that
we're seeing
anyone have any thoughts about that
i promised ben that would be a lively
bunch tonight
rob go for it come on
and meet rob he can mute himself rob
come on i don't think he can i think if
you've muted him you can't
there we go hello
hi down at the holiday park in westwood
we've already been in contact with the
new owners
of the um shipyard um and they're
having a chat with us in about 10 days
time with the uh
idea of they might bring some guys down
here uh from a way
to stay in the accommodation down here
um on the campsite with the chalets and
things like that out of season so there
might be a little bit of money coming in
from
these um these guys which might come
down to start up the yard
um which would be nice to get a few
extra pennies in the winter so there'll
be some bums on seats around the area i
would have thought um
that's all i can say on it really but
that might happen it happened before
when it was the ship yeah we had lots of
people staying in there
in westwood good news when did the
shipyard close
uh in march i think it was but it but it
was it wasn't it was busy
you know years before that it wasn't
much going on in march i think yeah
march 2019 all right i've got another
question for you that i'm hoping
will elicit a little bit of comments so
i was talking before about this
issue of identity and it's particularly
interesting in a place like
biddeford which feels to me as though
it's got
a lot of um a lot going for it a lot of
sort of
very clear assets but i wonder whether
it's got a very clear messaging in terms
of what
um what it's saying to the outside world
let's just say so if you were
a complete stranger to biddeford and you
came in what would you
what would you make of it uh what would
you make of its
evening uses what do you think the you
know would would you think it was a
a city you'd like to stay in for
instance a town that you'd like to stay
in
if you'd visited it what do you think
its messaging is to the outside world
does anybody have any thoughts on that
one
becky
there we go um if i was brutally honest
um i would say the town doesn't have an
awful lot going for it apart from
weather spoons and obviously um
but it's very dead um it used to be
quite lively in the evening it's not
now obviously recovered but even before
um and i think we have too many drunks
everywhere
which ruin the area especially for
children i've got children
and we don't go in victoria park because
of the drunk so
it's probably not the best message
yes it's very it feels that there's a
very clear message there's there's this
thing about you know the coaches drop
off in a certain
all drop off on on the sort of key side
basically
sure and then you have to like run the
gauntlet if you're coming into town
through them and that's not the best
first impression is it
no um so that's interesting the thing
about the evening economy as well
um so there's that thing about um
[Music]
we've got um theresa and i think joel
have also raised their hands about that
last point teresa go for it
uh yes um just thinking about first
impressions
coming driving in from barnstable uh
past the royal hotel you know it would
be so much better
when brunswick wharf is developed the
actual first
impressions will be will be so much
improved
because when you come in now to see
those broken down buildings
that with the iv gradually growing all
over them
it's just terrible really really poor
impression
um so you know the sooner
from my point of view the sooner
brunswick wharf can be
developed the better
would you say teresa that's actually
sadly the case from most directions when
you approach benefit at the moment
yes um
uh i i i i
i suppose it is really coming down from
valley road right no coming coming down
um hayward road is quite nice
yeah okay right i'm gonna i'm aware that
joel's been waving his hand
both uh digitally and in person go for
it joel
i just wanted to pick up that that's
that's something you know
people that choose to drink on the
street uh
is an issue that we need to be dealing
with as biddeford antorage
and giving people an opportunity to um
you know an alternative
to choosing to drink it life's life's
all about choices at the moment they're
choosing to drink on the street
possibly because there's no other
alternative or no other options for them
they are people they're not just drunks
or street drinkers
and we need to provide these people with
opportunity and training or some kind of
uh neurological development
because they may be neurologically
diverse as well so
we need to look at this as is part of
our town that is part of our town
that they vote for councillors they vote
for politicians they have
the exactly the same rights as all of us
and we need to make sure that they're
included
i think it's a really interesting point
joel in terms of the interconnection
between
something like addiction um then
mental health homelessness general
well-being
and employment opportunities so it is
about how we create a more holistic town
that is compassionate but also has high
standards
um uh david over to you
okay good evening yeah i mean i just
wanted to sort of bring up
the you know you're talking about the
opportunities of uh
of appledore and uh
and westwood ho right next door because
we've got um you know festivals
appledore um you know it does have a
quite a thriving sort of nightlife
here normally and then also you've got
westwood hoe as well with the beach
and and that sort of connectivity and
they to have those
um two locations so close to biddeford
um i think is a real opportunity you
know teresa sort of mentioned about
developing the cycle route but i think
there's a way that
i mean we are so close to one another
northern
appall and westwood hoe that there ought
to be a way of us being able to
benefit from one another and support one
another because i think that you know
we thrive when you know northern and
april and westwood
thrive when biddeford thrives and i just
think that there
there are opportunities there for us to
to develop
so that you know we bring a lot of
visitors to come to appledore
and to to westwood ho but they also
could go in
and do shopping and use biddeford much
more as a sort of a
another place to visit shop um and yeah
and i think so david that was exactly
the kind of the rationale uh to a
certain degree behind
a lot of the isaac's yard uh proposal
was the future high sheet fund
it's about an interaction between the
three locations
rather than just seeing them all in in
isolation
i'm aware that um peter's been waiting
very patiently thank you peter and then
i'm also aware that shirley has as well
i'll come in now and yeah i'm just going
back a bit actually when uh we were
asked
what would what do we think people's
first impressions of biddeford
are um i can actually remember mine
because i turned up in 1976
and i i couldn't have lived anywhere in
north devon and i went around all the
places and i turned up in biddeford and
thought
this is the place i want to live because
uh firstly the river
it was just stunning and the bridge
but biddeford itself was quirky
it's not a clone town like so many
others i mean basketball could be
anywhere
now literally anywhere in britain
biddeford is still very much itself
and that's something i think we need to
um actually build on
uh partly our architecture partly our
history
um i will just mention the nighttime
economy nighttime economies
come and go i suppose rob braddock will
agree to that sometimes they are up
sometimes they're down
people are very fickle of where they go
uh brunswick wharf i i think teresa
raised um
brunswick wharf we were due to have the
plans in
back in may now i know covered as
obviously interrupted all that but
uh it wasn't that long after the
lockdown so
we're not quite certain what's happened
to those plans i know there's been some
sort of public consultation but
uh we're still waiting to see what is
actually planned there i know there have
been artist impressions and so on but
uh we are still waiting for the actual
plans themselves
okay shelley
thank you um just to say that
in terms of first impressions i used to
when i was a kid i mean i didn't live
around here and uh we used to come down
on holiday to cornwall
and always arriving
and seeing the estuaries and seeing the
boats on the rivers
um and hearing the sounds and and
every time i come over the new bridge
and look down at the river
either direction i just have to pinch
myself to think i'm so
lucky to live somewhere that brings back
all those wonderful memories of going on
holiday as a child
and um i'm not don't want to you know
watch too lyrical about it because
obviously there's a lot of
issues but i just think we are blessed
with
with some of the things in our
surroundings
as peter has said about the river and
everything um i think we've got to make
more of the river somehow but also
blessed with westwood north et cetera
um just outside our town um
and i just think somehow we've got to
hold on to that and make the most of
that and remember those
i mean i take the point about if you
come into benefit a different direction
and everything but
um and i also do take the point about
issues with um certain people in the
town and things like that but equally
when you go in the park i mean i've been
in the park and
we have relatives from elsewhere in the
country and they come down and i know it
won't be this year but they use the
paddling pool and they just say
this is amazing this is fantastic what a
great facility
um you've got to hang on to all this and
then walking along the key they love it
and i know there's a lot of negatives
and i i'm
um but i just think we've got to hold on
to all those good things
and and make more of them thank you
thank you
i'm going to come to you in a second but
i i i'm aware that bert hasn't spoken
yet so i'm going to
leap over you to bert pretty please
hello can you see me we can't see you
but we can hear you nice and clearly um
all right yeah there we go
now we can see you okay um
yeah i'm just at living here really and
i live in westwood hall
um and um i've lived near near biddeford
for the last 15 years or so
um and i'm aware a bit of it has
challenges but i agree with
quite a lot of the other speakers that
um you know the town has got amazing
assets
um you know just being one of the major
ports
in england um you know centuries ago
it's still a working port and i'll come
back to that
um you know what i haven't quite heard
yet is that
um a bit of now has two town centers
essentially
um atlantic village now called affinity
um you know partly because it's so
easily accessible
you know by by cars and that won't go
away
you know um and having been
in the past should now disagree with um
campaigning against the new
prince's hate development in exeter um
i'm aware that most uh larger than
national chains
need larger premises so a bit of a town
center hasn't got that
and it's you know it's you know i'm sad
to hear that emanco is gone
it's one of the last because i'm aware a
farm where
national chains isn't probably not what
we what we can aim for
and but a bit of it has the possibility
of being an incredibly
attractive um place to visit for summer
visitors as well as for
people further away with living within
devon
and it doesn't meet all of those uh
attractive factors and i'll get
a bit more concrete i don't know how
other um town centers that deal with
similar problems deal with it
but and i'm aware that it probably
requires funding as well but
a swat team you know or um you know fast
response team to
shops that or you know premises that
look
drabby that look bad um sometimes owners
you know that struggle or whatever in a
town center need a bit of help or a new
reminder just just a reminder that
everybody can see
you know that their premises the
premises look bad
and if all premises in the town look
good or
even if they're vacant they're filled as
quickly as possible
and it really helps because once you get
an air of despondency or
you know this time is down a hill and it
stops visitors from coming
that are local or or or visitors from
during the
summer season um apart from that i agree
with um peter christie about
the park and the idea of you know
parking is really important
because people love just dropping off
and you know not not paying that pounded
at two pounds um
and everybody wants to walk a long way
i'm really excited about the possible
plans of
creating a new hub um between all helen
street and mill street
which is but please don't turn into a
green lane shopping center
like in like in barnstable there are
historic features there
walls
and um you know but the potential is
amazing but you just still still need
people to spend their pounds
um then i've just got two
um clear blue thinking ideas and and the
first one
may uh be financially and and maybe i
may be shot down on
but um it's fantastic that the british
still a working town
a working port but how much money does
it actually bring in during high tides
to get the occasional big ship in
um you've got a very busy high street
plus a key that is basically a parking
spot
it's our biggest asset um if we're going
to be a tourist town
it needs to be attractive there could be
cafes there with uh
sidewalks and you know um
cafe you know um outdoor eating and
drinking
and the last one and this is ultimate
blue
sky thinking is i'm not sure the heist
the high street needs to be
um have cars in it but
i've been to hong kong years ago and
there's a very high part of the island
of hong kong
which is lovely but it's hard to reach
it reminds me a bit of um the penny
market and it's got an escalator
and there are a few other towns in the
world that have an
barcelona escalator another one which
one
barcelona after this cigarette emilia um
you know i know
i probably haven't got the funding but
it's a blue sky idea
um why not have an escalated opinion
market and connect
the two places that way thank you okay
i'm aware
joel can you go for a quick one and then
on to sadie please
yeah just briefly i was going to say a
bit more but i'll keep it brief everyone
keeps talking about um the river and
coming back to boats and
you know maritime history at one point
we were the second
port to london i just don't understand
why we don't celebrate that with a
instead of you know building flats let's
build a museum
let's have some gig building colleges
let's build boats
in conjunction with the the boat boat
yard down the
road and let's link it all with water
taxes
why not let's get the ferry back from
milforcoon to wales let's let's get boat
building
let's do it right uh to
sadie please and then i'm aware uh
joanne's been waving around as well
sadie where have you gone
hello hey sadie we can see we can hear
you go for it
yeah um actually what joel said
was what i was going to say actually so
yeah we need to make the most of our
river
it's beautiful it's not made enough of
at the moment currently we've got a
couple of rowing clubs that use it
it would be lovely to have some kind of
water sport facility
dealing with all the history of our town
which is
amazing and go you know we have got so
many things that you know kids
and grown-ups locally don't know about
about our history here
um i mean really if we could tie it all
together
the beautiful scenery the beautiful
river the beautiful buildings in the
town
um you know we have such an amazing well
we've just got such a lot to offer and i
agree with peter as well that
we have a quirky biddeford town centre
and i like that
you don't want to have all those big you
know like costas
and things coming into our town we need
to be we need to be
biddeford and you know we've already got
a lot to offer history and
river and the whole thing
the pannier market i think also um yeah
needs to be utilized more sorry i'll be
quiet
so you know feel free so for me i think
there's a couple of really great points
there and to pick up on
quirky makes people smile and for me
someone who's lived in biddeford for um
15 years
biddeford is a town that likes to smile
the people like to smile
it should be a real central point of who
we are
and what we're selling that actually
it's a relaxed fun
kind place to be um in terms of the
history of the town i think we'd all
agree that the museum
sort of squashed into the top of the
burton has got loads of great stuff but
doesn't necessarily engage
through that i know they've been doing
some work on it but actually within the
isaac's yard proposals that's a certain
degree
and peter's been involved in these
conversations as well um
was when the driving forces of having
that cultural
sort of anchor to really celebrate in an
engaging
occasionally technology-driven way to
bring a lot of that to life
well also if you can bring schools in
and groups you know as a school teacher
myself there's no way that we can really
bring in a massive group to the burton
art gallery as much as we'd love to
and once you can tie in all those things
schools
and people that enjoy the river
then you know we've got a lot of things
going for us
people coming back over and over yeah
completely joanne thank you so much for
waiting
oh can't hear you oh no frustrating
a tiny bit go for it i think we're gonna
just about strain in and hear you
i i want to i'll talk louder then um i
wanted to
raise the point is there anything that
needs to change for the town to thrive
and i think that
absolutely we need to we're talking
about investment here we're talking
about
um spending money on the town to bring
people in but actually we we have money
in the town
that goes out of the town we have money
that that we bring
in that goes out of the area and that
goes out of the area in the form of
supermarkets
and we have large supermarkets that take
millions and millions of pounds out of
this area every year
and and one of the things that north
devon food companies is looking at
is how to keep that money in this area
how to keep it
in the town how to invest in businesses
how to grow our food economy
and how to use our resources to keep
growing biddeford and the other towns so
so
um we're looking at not just
sustainability here but regeneration
so we're looking at regenerative farming
at growing the food that we want to eat
and we're doing it collectively so we're
using our money
um as we would go to a shop or a
supermarket and we're
going direct to the farmer and saying
can you grow this because this is what
we want to eat and we're
looking at putting money up front using
the power of the collective
to support growers to grow their
business our
our biggest challenge is access to land
we've got the growers we've got
identified the the people that we want
to work with and we've identified a lot
of people
that want to come on board with a co-op
um we
there'll be lots of spin-offs with this
it's not just talking about food but
anything that we can grow that we can
utilize in this area
will potentially be a business so you're
talking about using
shops but actually we've got the we've
got all the expertise we need here
and we actually have the money between
us to make this work
what we what we're trying to do is just
to put it all together
so we are looking at certain things like
um
educating people around food and where
your food is grown and
and how you use food for health looking
at affordability
how we can cut out certain steps of the
food process
so that we can make good food more
affordable and more accessible
um we're talking about uh having a
year-round economy
economy so that we're just not relying
on on tourism the whole time but
actually we're
self-sustaining and also attractive
attracting funding because
a food co-op is a non-profit and um and
we should be able to attract various
grants
so um you know with this is about
localism this is about
us supporting us by spending our money
with the local businesses
who are who are growing food and growing
their own products here um
and we're at the very start of creating
our vision um we'd like to use the
pannier market not
for a market but actually as a killer
can collect point
so um farmers and the food growers have
told us the way the model that they want
to work
um they don't want to do deliveries they
don't want to stand at a market stall
all day
they want to put their products on a
website we order click and pay
and they deliver it to one central point
and we can collect it so that's their
preferred model
um it's it saves them time they
they know in advance what um what their
orders are going to be and
all the money is handled you know your
website
um
it sounds really exciting one thing i'm
i'm going to chip in um
as part of the future high sheet funds i
put this into
uh the chat because people often laugh
at me when i start saying this
and when the inspirations for the
sort of food elements of the isaac's
yard was a place called mercato
metropolitano
um in elephant and castle in london
who really it's not just about the great
locally sourced
produce but it's about how you educate
through that food both for kind of
the adult community and for schools of
children's
to make sure that actually that message
just becomes completely embedded within
the local community
and sort of makato even kind of do uh
summer programs for students on uh free
school meals for example so it's
actually it's that sense
going back to joel's point earlier on
about that compassionate society
okay joel over to you thank you john
that's really interesting also
go for it i'm just going to say
education will be part of the cult
because we've got people who are
who are growing and obviously they'll
they'll be
seasonal and we'll need to educate
people about the best way to eat
seasonal food
brilliant thank you very much joel did
you want to chip in
uh yeah just quickly uh just following
on from joe i think that's a
really great idea but it always struck
me that
we live in um you know we're surrounded
by a huge farm
and and whenever i teach in schools
around the area if the food
comes from you know probably a weird
dusty warehouse in germany somewhere
it's like
why can't we supply our own schools on
our own
you know why is there not a gcse in
farming
that we do in north devon or b tech or
well i'm actually i'll tell you about
i'm sure there is a b tech actually at
the agricultural college but why is
there not a gcse
in farming we need to really concentrate
on we should be measuring our um
food miles in meters really here
shouldn't we
i know it was actually something that
route 39 were looking into partnering
with duchy on
and the department for education got
slightly um funny about it
um so because again at the moment we
send a lot of our young people off
to duchy or to victon um
so but i think food education is coming
back into schools far more than it used
to it kind of died away
um it's now a far more prominent thing i
think i'm reluctant to start going into
the world of education too much
um because i think it'd be useful to
really focus on
town center for now but it's all
interconnected uh
ben i'm aware you've got a fair bit to
get through
um whilst ben's talking can we please
make sure we carry on these
conversations
um through the chat which is merrily
kind of ticking away in the corner of my
screen
ask actually adrian do you mind um
giving us a quick sort of pre-see of the
chat what's going on
uh yeah sure sorry i'm just making sure
yeah i'm unmuted
uh that's a good point there's a lot of
positives um
especially around around the structure
of town and the appearance of the town
you know
definitely wanting to keep uh keep
biddeford's quirkiness
um going on you know it's really
important to people
um ideas um potentially around
the museum going to where the library is
um and that could create
a big space for for the town museum um
other bits as well but you know trying
to keep the money the bit of a pound
in biddeford you know lots of dusty
airbnb
um that sort of thing that disappears
out of the town having those ideas to
try and keep that spent within the town
as well
um also a bit interesting about eminco
shutting and being in a big
and a lot of the a lot of the shop
owners being
obviously the private owners but
actually they potentially don't live
here
which is um which could be could be
potential
uh problem with the with the appearance
of the of the shop upkeep then if you
like so
maybe to look at something you know look
at that um and if that's
that needs addressing maybe um
yeah really that's that's pretty much it
but they're all positive
um on the group chat from here you know
things about sculptures being put up as
well
um which is which is all good for the
town so yeah that's that's the
update on the chat there brilliant
thanks so much all right
i'm going to take it really negative now
i'm really sorry i feel quite bad about
it
i wanted to talk about coronavirus um
particularly
and what's happened economically um
obviously this is a
this is something that we've all seen
and got used to seeing over the last
um few months um and and sort of on a
national stage and what i'd like you to
be thinking about as i go through this
uh is sort of how you would compare
biddeford to what's been happening
nationally
and so obviously businesses had to close
and remain closed for some time although
certainly in biddeford we've seen lots
of businesses staying open that that had
a sort of um
you know that were an essential retailer
and but what we've
what we've been seeing is it is a
decline for some time
and where uh in 2018 and 2019 we were
gradually seeing uh job losses and store
closures going up
now as a conservative estimate we're now
forecasting 235
704 job losses uh in 2020 with twenty
thousand
six hundred and twenty uh store closures
now um i'm quite struck by um
the gentleman franklin who was i'm so
sorry um
about this idea that that then really
should be attracting more chains and
that it's not really attractive to
chains
i think you've judged a bit of a bullet
there as far as i'm as far as
certainly in terms of the national
example um
it it it has been protected in many ways
because a lot of changes started moving
out
thank you the evening economy the
restaurants the pub but also
uh the shops as well um and actually i
think we've seen far
fewer store closures in biddeford than
we have on a national stage
um it's looking at some of the sort of
key uh
industry areas and policy areas that
i've been looking at
as far as um the national picture is
concerned
hospitality has been it's been a really
interesting one
it's been quite a roller coaster it was
in a load of trouble before anyway
um labor shortages spiraling rents bad
management
um you know the sort of threat of brexit
on on on let on labor was was a
real problem for the industry and it's
going to be very interesting to
understand how it's going to adapt boost
brexit post covid
eat out help out certainly when i was in
biddeford meant there wasn't a a table
to be found in town
um maybe that means there's more
capacity certainly a lot of those
restaurants are now
looking to expand into into september
station infrastructure is a really
interesting one and very very well made
point about the fact that that you know
there are all sorts of different people
in town
some of whom have got all sorts of
different kinds of uh of issues
substance abuse problems and mental
health issues
you know they are all part of that
bedford family i wonder whether there's
this issue now around
the money that's around to be able to
deal with these sorts of issues but also
whether there's there's you know we've
seen this resurgence of the notion of
community i suppose and people have been
helping each other a lot more their
vulnerable neighbors their
uh and volunteering and that sort of
thing as well
i mentioned a little bit uh before about
this this sort of change in in our
working patterns
think about it in terms of biddeford
lots more people working from home
hashtags companies you know cutting back
on office space
not loads of office space in biddeford i
would predict that a lot more people
leave biddeford than come to british
from outside to work
particularly in offices so this this
changes our demand patterns
um it's also true that the population
there will be changes in the population
maybe
a little bit less so in north devon both
on the at the older end and the younger
end
as a result of lockdown um
and also just thinking about tourism you
know we there's no getting over it
it's been a really interesting year
actually for
biddeford you know the the airlines have
obviously not been
not been running but you've really seen
a lot of staycationers in town
how the things change next year you know
what did 2020 ultimately look like was
that made back from
from uh from people that that are
visiting from
the domestic market um and are we gonna
lose some visual economy businesses or
do you think that it will still
survive think about that in terms of the
action plan now i just wanted to run
through
i've got loads of time but i just wanted
to run through um
how some of these places particularly
small towns
are dealing with with recovery um
and there are just some examples here
the first is this idea of the virtual
high street so
uh north allerton uh soltaire kendall uh
are all using this uh shop happy virtual
high street app
which is really about taking the high
street online those places where
there are lots of good independence but
also where you'll see shoppers
um who essentially go from one shop to
the other to get their daily shop or
their weekly shop
these sorts of um interventions work
really well
you can order it all online and then go
in and collect it
a really good way of sort of tying that
that sort of virtual and
and sort of real high street together
and loyal free which is being used by
well and garden city atlantic and
olveston
um they're they're uh they're much
they're quite interesting as well
it's a bit less about they can collect a
little bit more about
tourist information town trails and
heritage
um so and also they do loads of stuff on
footfall as well so
for data they're really good on data so
it's definitely one to consider i think
um for different especially given you've
got all of these issues around
all of these positives around heritage
and history and trails and that sort of
thing and a lot
explorations are going on into a couple
of those at the moment
so fantastic again lots of places to
discover a bit of difference
so yeah absolutely have a look at those
um
this is manchester so obviously way
bigger than uh biddeford but
really interesting campaigns i know that
plymouth
um no i'm so sorry falmouth
uh which is obviously much smaller than
plymouth uh in some really interesting
campaigns which is around
me welcome back um there are you know
there are all sorts of things that you
can
you can to welcome people back my door's
just gone i'm going to ignore it
um and then um there's this issue
around encouraging new businesses so
obviously you do have some vacancy
um and uh oppositionally has done a
really interesting project around so
it's got
a fair bit of money together actually
it's about doing
vacant units up you certainly can
interface with your
landlords um to do that and then filling
them with meanwhile spaces this is
really about
encouraging enterprise um and sort of
working with local
um uh educational establishments and
others for those people that want to
start
their own businesses in town so there's
real opportunities there
um we talked about um this idea about
local economic um uh power for those
people that are working from home
those of you that have got kids i i feel
for you if you've been working from home
over the last
few months it had not been easy where
are those offices disappearing some
people will really have no choice but to
come into town and work and if you think
about the sort of
agglomerative effects of people working
together
what that means is um the people you
know will be
found in the same place and economically
that's really good for a place
is not only there are the impacts of
them going off and getting the sandwich
from the local
sandwich shop but actually they're
learning from each other and that's
what's really good about local
uh work clubs um
finally uh well not quite finally but
but community community wealth building
which absolutely speaks
to that model that joanne was talking
about before this idea of local wealth
creation
and keeping money in the community so um
uh the preston model is a really
interesting example of this
and it looks at these four key
principles essentially using wealth
that's
already in your community keeping it in
your community
particularly those local institutions
the local authorities
housing associations others that have
got spending power
keeping that wealth in the community and
using the workforce to make sure that
they're paid properly and to encourage
them to both save and spend locally
using credit unions and other
institutions um
using land and property right in in the
right ways
and so you know where the local
authority i mean you know
cpo is not it is a sorry compulsory
purchase order is a
is a sort of power that's available to
local authorities but actually there are
other ways
being able to acquire land and use it
for the benefit of local wealth creation
and then finally economic democracy
which is really about
local governance models that encourage
that uh local spend um
community property trusts is one that's
really popular in in
in north devon um so you know building
housing locally and that sort of thing
um
just to go on to a report by bill
grimsey um
who used to be the ceo of iceland and
wix and it's a fantastic
you've read it haven't you chris it's a
really it sounds strange and please feel
free to accuse me of being geeky
but it's actually a really enjoyable
uplifting thing
it's really interesting i mean it's not
it's not uplifting in the beginning
because
because bill grimsby puts his hands up
and says i ruined the high street and
i'm really sorry and
um i mean that that as a sort of uh maya
culprit
is really interesting one you know they
they were absolutely part and parcel of
creating these clean towns
um of sort of bringing people out to out
of town shopping centers and that sort
of thing
and so his response to all of that is a
lot
that's been talked about tonight the
first is again joanne you were talking
about this idea of localism
absolutely bang on you know you need
local
uh governance relationships that mean
that people are in much much greater
control
of the picture of their place
um the second is leadership and i know
that biddeford is totally
full of really really great leaders you
might but some of them are on the call i
know and some of you might think
it's always down to me but actually what
leadership
inspires is other people to do it as
well and so
councils councils need to empower those
leaders to go out and recruit people
that are able to make a real difference
in biddeford and i know that a lot lots
of that's going on
this final one i mean you might be
a bit uh anti the fewer cars thing but
certainly you'll be
pro the the green space thing um let's
see how the parking thing works but
what bill is saying here is that
town cities everywhere needs to think a
little bit more about how their spaces
are configured
to really encourage people to stop enjoy
dwell
one of the uh i think one of the things
i was told about the high street is that
it
has to have spaces that allow people to
stop directly out of the shop
pop in buy their stuff and then drive
away again
i don't know about you that's not what
i'd want for my town i want people to
stop i want people to dwell i want
people to
have a cup of coffee spend a bit more
money and enjoy
the sort of pace of life um i think
that's popular the same
yeah ben there's only one disappointment
i've got with uh
grimsey and that's the fact that i
tweeted him
uh before our future high street fund
submission to to get his thoughts and he
just blanked me
i don't he's been a bit of a busy boy i
don't think it was personal
i'm aware ben that um yeah we've got
lots and lots absolutely as well
there's lots in the chat and joel's been
sat very patiently with his hands i'm
terribly sorry john i've got everyone i
can't see anyone so
so please please go ahead
uh just i've got three points but i'll
be really brief
now the first is maybe a biddeford pound
could be a winner
brixton's got one bristol's got one and
our name is very similar
but it works it works it keeps cash
local uh you don't
you're not allowed to spend it in the
big chains interestingly it worked
briefly in tottenhams and then didn't
work
um so it's a case of making sure that
anything we do has that sustainable
long-term
impact and i think that's key um
definitely sorry point number two i'm
sorry the brixton pound and the bristol
pound so i
used to uh run bits at business
improvement districts in london and i
saw i was very closely connected with
the prison pound and now i live in
bristol and i'm closely connected with
crystal pound
and i'm afraid they're both slightly on
the skids um
but what i would say is that a place
like biddeford is
if it's ever going to work it's going to
work in somewhere that has loads of
independence and lots of people
supporting them so
don't give up on the idea at all
second point really briefly is that
paris is now looking
at a system where you can get everything
you need
within 15 a 15-minute walk yeah
joe that was absolutely integral to our
future high street funds and
the the concept of a 15-minute
neighborhood um
whereby you can get everything you want
in terms of shopping
leisure um well-being opportunities
and your work sort of high quality work
within 15 minutes of where you live
and i guess that would be for london
derry and east of the water as well
yeah and especially if we then start
working on things like e-bike
opportunities and
improved cycling um opportunities which
then
expands that sort of radius and really
means that people can access that
15-minute neighborhood
and also i was just wondering do you or
ben or adrian have any information
on the um positive effects
of educational facilities within a town
centre because i would love to see
we've got the burton is you know it's
one of the best galleries in the country
that we've got in biddeford and to have
that art college
kind of not being an art college
opposite one of the best
galleries in the country is just
heartbreaking every time i walk past it
especially and i'm an art teacher as
well so it's double heartbreaking
but that that place could we've we've
got an amazing again we've got a
maritime history we've got an amazing
artistic history as
as well here in the in the town and
that's something that again needs to be
celebrated i think
and i'm sure if you've got some crazy 18
19 year old art students they're going
to bring a lot to the town
i think they really would i'm boat
building students
yeah um victoria i'm gonna agree that
kind of uh
the sense of uh having an app to bring
not only modernity but linking different
strands is gonna be really important
but what we also need to make sure is
that we get it right when we do it so
that it is holistic
um right ben back to you
well i say we i i've seen that we've got
43 in the chat
so adrian do you want to give us a quick
run through yeah
it's just some some general conversation
going on about
um about again going back to the
locality of our food it's been produced
and
and how we can potentially um see that
being used within our towns for people
coming in
and purchasing that as a food hub for
that that's quite a bit of the
quite a bit of the conversation but also
on transport and local links
and from our villages and maybe some
work needed around that as well
and where they go and drop off and use
using those areas
um a little bit better potentially um
but yeah mostly around having a food hub
being such a great idea and then
obviously victoria chris has picked up
on that about
the um about the app and we know that
hamish is has been doing some
investigations around that
um potentially as an idea as well and
how we can bring
bring the high streets to the living
room but keep keep the pound within
biddeford um as well so um yeah that's
mostly
um mostly what that conversations are
about there ben
brilliant thank you very much it's
really really interesting actually this
is very um
this is very rich conversation it does
actually remind me slightly of i mean
still
when we're talking about demand patterns
really um
that 15-minute city thing is absolutely
bang on for that
um the bid of the pound thing is
absolutely bang on for that
and then also that comment about making
greater economic connections between the
outer lying areas
of biddeford and the villages and stuff
and actually technology allows you to do
that
uh and it's increasingly allow you to do
that with transports those sort of
bus networks are community bus networks
that are
run by algorithm so you can order them
up like you would a cab and it works out
you know the sort of best most efficient
way to get between those people that
have ordered them up
and it's really disappointing that uh
someone who was on last night's call and
will be on tomorrow night's call
is an expert on that but she had to
ascend her apologies for tonight
she works at devon county council so
that there are
within the district investigations into
that brilliant okay
really good for for yeah for
particularly for rural areas
um so just talking about uh demand
patterns just looking at this this slide
here obviously
um we've got people working from home
i i spent a number of different state
agents in bitter food when i was down
and they're all extremely positive but
but and i don't know whether this will
fill you with horror
but um a lot a lot of
inquiries from people moving from cities
into north devon
so they're really you know they they you
will see a change
i think who knows whether these
inquiries you know ended up coming to
anything
but but you'll see a change in people
coming from outside they were saying
it used to be retirees now it's younger
people with families
really we're interested in changing that
life style
and also suddenly aware that you don't
need to be tied to any specific place
so let's see what that does in terms of
uh
um work working patterns and
broadband is another really interesting
one um uh
communities are doing for themselves
these days there's a really interesting
um example of that in lancashire there's
a sort of community
um broadband to build it yourself
network called barn
um they literally dug their own trenches
through the fields and now have one of
the
um fastest fiber networks in the country
thankfully ben
bit benefit is scheduled to have full
fiber across the entire town by the end
of 21.
brilliant good here good here um retail
is you know obviously there's retail
demand patterns
are changing there's been a real
research resurgence grocery
um there's a lot of revised opening
hours i've seen it in biddeford anyway
that blending with online and that
support for independence so that's good
as well
and then we spoke already about rural
housing
um right ben could i just get asked
and i know that kay earlier on wanted to
pick up on a point about
um sort of social issues within the town
okay
hi thank you for letting me talk i can't
stay on long i've got kids in the
background first day back at school
and a few of you might know me so i'm
i'm doing this k
modest on here but i'm councilman k corp
i'm with a tongue count song
and so my
my job is working with vulnerable people
for a local charity called inhumphus and
i actually manage
an eight-bedroom shared supported
accommodation project
in biddeford central biddeford town and
for people that were homeless
and have had or got issues such as
alcohol
substance misuse mental health and
things like that so i just really really
wanted to come on and chat to you guys
and i'm aware that earlier in today's
meeting before i came on
that the people that drink on the key
were discussed i don't know if that was
quite brief
and i know that at the last time council
meeting
there was a conversation as well about
them being an issue
unfortunately i wasn't at that meeting
i'll be quite honest with you guys it's
something that is
that i'm really really passionate about
i mean people in my life and supporting
people that don't have a voice
in our community and making sure that we
can get as many people accommodated as
possible
and one of the points i really wanted to
bring this evening
is and i'm not sure if everyone's aware
of this
the people that are on the key drinking
are not
breaking sorry i'm not breaking
any laws there's no
there's no i don't know what the word is
but there's no reason why they can't
drink i've spoke to dean at torridge and
you know and i know for a lot of people
they say it can be quite
intimidating and it can be quite
unsightly but they are members of our
community as well
and these members of our community are
the ones that have been
hit hardest through the pandemic
they were struggling anyway and these
people are struggling even more now
and you know i am going to be really
careful because like i said i am quite
passionate but i know
each and every one of these people
really well so i know their backstory i
know their history
and i know their struggles and i've lost
my bit of paper i'm always doing that
but i wrote something down the other
night
and to actually say it the next time
council meeting but i'll try and
remember some of it tonight
and quite often in my job you know we
have a lot of people
that are labeled as problems and it's
not until the labels
and the labeler can come together
and talk about that perceived problem
that actually we very quickly realize
that it's not really a problem at all
and that by working together
we can look at the perceived problem and
work through it
does that kind of make sense i don't
need to think i'm going off on a bit of
a tangent but
you know these are people in our
community they're people's
brothers sons uncles fathers nephews
cousins friends
and then you know i know for a fact that
if they had an
alternative other than to sit there
and drink and be perceived as unsightly
and causing an issue than they would
but for them that is their world right
now
and at encompass we are quite
effectively working with people in that
situation
unfortunately due to obviously funding
issues and resources we can't get to
everybody
but you know these guys and girls are
still going to be there
when it gets colder you know when things
get harder for all of us
financially and job issues and
accommodation
and i just wanted to kind of come here
tonight and be a bit of a voice for them
so we can just all remember that
they're struggling as well if anybody's
got any questions that would be great
kate i think it's really important that
we remember kind of throughout this
process
that what we're talking about is
opportunities for all
and that what we can't do is say right
we're going to invest massively in our
town and create opportunities
for some that this is about for example
how do we create better employment
routes how do we create a more
supportive society to catch those people
who've fallen through gaps
and how do we make sure that there's
improved housing
how do we make sure that we have
environmental aspects
very much at the heart of what we're
doing be that kind of either in plastic
free or be
in terms of the carbon message how do we
make sure that kind of our young people
are provided for
both through things like and old in
terms of transport opportunities and
leisure activities
because our young people often get
stigmatized because they're hanging
around with nothing to do
what's because there's nothing to do so
we need to make sure that we're not
having a
mono-dimensional conversation but
actually
we are broad-reaching um so i think
i'm aware that we're kind of almost
running out of time kay and i'm aware
that kind of you and i
have often talked in the past about this
one for a long period of time
um so i'm sort of i'd like to give
ben the opportunity just to carry on for
a moment but
please please please i know sadie's
already put a comment in um
the the chat for you might be worth just
kind of uh
using that chat function for a few
minutes and really kind of
passing some messages around is that
okay yeah just very quickly and
um not in this meeting obviously but if
anyone wants to get in touch with me
because they
encompass we've got lots and lots of
different projects and we've got lots of
statistics
and information about all those things
you've just said chris about the young
people unemployment housing
so i think we could work really
collectively work together on that
yeah if you need more than okay your
contact details are all on the biddeford
town council
um website i believe so if anyone's
interested in getting in touch
uh with kay then her contact is all
through there
okay a pleasure absolute pleasure and
ben where we've got about 10 minutes
how many things that you want to steer
us towards discussing well only just to
sort of and
thanks very much that came it's really
uh interesting important uh
thing to say there and i just wanted to
talk about the sort of context of the
of the of the action plan itself um
obviously it needs to fit in as much as
possible
um with the sort of strategic plans
above it in the hierarchy i know that
the town council has plans as well
this really just needs to be something
which is almost like a list of things
that have been
um that have been sort of mentioned uh
mentioned over there
over the time just to sort of get it
down on paper and provide you with a bit
of a
direction of travel you know these
aren't these are going to be short
medium long term
things that should be achievable but
i suppose the focus needs to be on what
the community can achieve
for itself so a lot of the um
the examples that i've used have really
been about you know
rather than sort of big infrastructural
spending they've been about
you know the community getting together
and deciding that they want to do a
specific thing in their town
and and i i know that biddeford is
really good for that because
you know i've met lots of people in the
town and i know that lots of you
work together and stuff so it's the
focus of it but i won't leave out
the bigger infrastructural plans now i
just very quickly wanted to run
through um what is above it and that in
the
hierarchy so particularly the north
devon recovery plan ben
apologies before we kind of move on to
that last bit sadie can i just come to
you as the final hand that's up
sorry ben yeah sorry i'll be really
brief
just i just wanted to say how lovely it
was to hear from kay
and all the work that's been um done
obviously around town
for people that are struggling um
also just going to say that you know
lots of teenagers
hanging around as well and those i think
as part of this i think we you know we
really must be careful not to leave
those people behind um it's all too easy
to sort of
you know say that they're intimidating
and everything but i really think that
they if they could be brought on board
wouldn't that be amazing um also
with my other hat on which i forgot to
mention earlier is that
plastic free communities um thing that
we've been doing around town
um again we've done a lot of work
locally
um we're just volunteers we haven't got
an amazing amount of time to go around
to each an individual business in town
but i think you know saying we were
quirky earlier
i really i really believe that if we can
show how differently we can react to
things and how we promote
maybe the environmental um also how we
care for our community i think that will
um i think that's a really
i think that could be a really key way
of showing how biddeford is very
different
and could be very different also
alongside all this
um you know investment and everything
else and recovering
the town but also remembering the people
within it that makes sense
a great place to live work and visit so
to speak yeah
yeah yeah but also you know caring for
those people that need it the most
because it's all too easy to sort of try
and push them to the side
i absolutely agree right ben over to you
let's look at that strategic overview
for a minute and i think say to your
point there is absolutely superb point
to move on
like and that absolutely meets that
long-term
um uh aspiration of of north devon for
that
net zero carbon society that sort of you
know
really looking at you know what plastics
are being used
by diversity gain and environmental
improvement
so that it's really working these are
quite these are some sort of quite
general
um long-term aspirations but in the
meantime obviously
you know uh chris has talked to some of
the uh
sort of term um aspirations around
uh isaac's yard and brandon dwarf um
it changes afoot and and then in the
short term
it's about supporting businesses with
grants
physical changes sound centers that
you've seen um
and just sort of helping those those
businesses recover so
i guess what i'm saying is that the the
action plan will need to fit in with
that
um and uh hopefully
they do now just very quickly in
barriers to success
um there are three that i see all the
time and i just want these to be in the
forefront of your mind
as you both read the action plan and and
and
go on to um suggest things that should
go in it so the first is really around
infrastructure fantastic news around
broadband
that that's going to be uh really up to
scratch
um transport again you know we were
speaking about that a little bit earlier
i'd really like to hook up with your
expert
chris if possible and just start talking
a little bit about that
um i know that the um the transport
catapult is around as well and late they
might go to
just a few things um and training as
well again back to sadie's point and
kay's point
this is really about bringing everyone
with you so you know
there's a real problem in rural
communities benefit included with this
brain drain of younger people that go
off to university
you know are the jobs available for them
and you know
isaac's yard other you know other
opportunities in biddeford
need to be created to encourage those
people to stay and be
economic units for their for the town as
well as um
great citizens um there's always a
problem with
lack of money um in fact actually just
in on the infrastructure thing i just
might say one other thing which has
not popped up at all and never seems to
pop up when you're talking about
biddeford
which is it's a pound completely
separated by water and
there doesn't appear to be very much on
one side of it
um i wonder whether some of you might
have
some opinions on whether or not their
needs again this is sort of the
15-minute city thing
you know whether maybe we need to
balance that a little bit maybe
brunswick
is an opportunity there but this is a
question about place and identity and
it's
a bit of a sort of slightly over
balanced thing
i can see things coming into the chat
there that's good um
uh and so is it so lack of money is is a
problem there's
there's issues around local governments
and partnerships i
am not massively okay with how a town
council works with the district council
works with a
county council works with a major
unitary council works with the left
i bet it's brilliant um i bet it's
really easy
um but you know what the issues there in
terms of sort of sharing visions and
that sort of thing
and then there's in terms of governance
you know with very very hyper local
governance
can you get the people involved that
need to get involved it's not just
it's not just our council's fantastic
job though they do
but it's like how do you how do you
really engage the citizens and it sounds
to me as though
um the work that's done recently on
isaac sharps are really excellent
um very very quickly before we go to
some final comments from you
so the action plan is coming to you in
about
uh three weeks time um which gives you
lots of opportunity to bung in your
ideas this
uh video is going on to the council
youtube
and facebook pages so an opportunity to
be able to
um uh contribute there um
and you know obviously all it will all
be checked and we'll look at the chat
and everything will be incorporated as
much as possible but what i wanted to do
is to be based on evidence so
if you're you know if the
if the car parking trial isn't working
or it needs to work in a different way
then i'll bring evidence to say i think
it needs to go this way so
it's not all going to be just reading
back what your what your sort of current
aspirations are
i want to sort of try to push it forward
a little bit as well
i want it to be community focused as i
said before so this is really around
you know it's it's really around what
you can do for yourselves rather than
necessarily what
the councils can do for you um i want it
however to be complementary to council
strategy there's been a lot of work
behind that
and it really is picking up those
broader issues around the vulnerable
people in society
the big strategic and sort of structural
issues around transport
jobs and well-being and skills and that
sort of thing
and then finally i would like it yeah to
challenge
you as much as possible to get out there
and change things
though it's a great place now just very
finally this is my final slide which is
just that
if you want to get in touch with me i'm
very very happy for you to phone me
please not four o'clock in the morning
um if you have a eureka moment but if
you've got any ideas i really really
want to hear them
and i'm very very happy to talk to you
and
do we have anybody else in their hand up
or or adrian is there anyone in chat
that uh you think needs to be
shared with the group
um i'm not sorry ben uh not not
currently it's it's slow down a little
bit
um a lot a few bits about um
you talking about the two sides of the
river and we're having a bridge a
pedestrian
stroke cycle bridge over the uh over the
river which i know we
we're just saying now it's been just um
discussed many times before and you know
and and it's currently been looked into
again um
but it's that trying to join the two up
that's the really the the conversation
at the minute um i'd also add adrian
that it's about
um building momentum so
rather than just sort of projects in
isolation
it's about for example getting
isaac's yard going and then building
interest in the attractiveness of the
town coupling that with brunswick
coupling that with hopefully getting
bridge buildings um
open again and then you start getting
people really interested about what's
happening
in our town and then sort of
opportunities like
cycle bridges start gaining traction
and start really becoming um possible
whereas
if it's a cycle bridge in isolation it
becomes a lot
harder to necessarily invest in and
justify
um although sort of i think most of us
in this cool would say that actually
that would be a fantastic exciting uh
thing
to increase the the flow between the
town centre
east the wharf eats the water and
brunswick wolf
i couldn't agree more there's that whole
thing about momentum
there are not enough hotels in town the
evening economy is not vibrant enough
for for a town of biddeford's size but
actually you start somewhere and place
in
things like isaac's yard or even just to
have a bit of investment from
local independent shops you will see a
change as a result of that and
i i see a confidence in biddeford that i
don't see in many many other towns so i
just
want to leave you on a reassuring note
you are you're dead right at biddeford
is an amazing place and
i am convinced that it will be
absolutely fine in the long term
and what a lovely way to finish the
evening
i might move there he did actually say
that to me when we were stood
uh looking down over the town a few
weeks ago
with the sun kind of as i said
glistening on the river
admittedly we couldn't find anywhere to
eat um but
our town has got a lot going for it and
fingers crossed we're in for exciting
times
i'm aware that we're approaching eight
o'clock i would encourage anyone who's
got
victoria i i'm not sure he does say that
about all the times actually
um i really do i really don't i promise
scout's honor
um but i think that please utilize those
contact details that ben put up um
as ben mentioned i will be sharing the
video of this session
onto the turret economic development
facebook page tomorrow
so if you need to kind of scribble those
down you haven't got a pen now
you can access them from that video
really thank you so much for
getting involved i know i know that
we've had various discussions but it
really is about building
these discussions and bringing more and
more and more people
in so that as ben mentioned we can make
sure that it's not just torridge it's
not just biddeford town council
but that our entire community can really
start
to feel proud and involved in their town
on that note everyone thank you so much
enjoy your evenings and i look forward
to speaking all again very soon
thanks chris thanks ben
cheers bye bye